you're supposed to die to gain Ichiro at
the start of the game but what if you
don't that thought was teasing me for
weeks after the game's release and as I
got good against him my mind began to
race with ideas maybe he won't cut my
arm off and maybe I'll go through the
game without a prosthetic arm what if
I'm able to turn his bow into a
prosthetic weapon I thought maybe the
credits will roll right here and now
game over
what if it's just oh oh at least there's
a little bit of law here the ash in a
combat style is all about victory at any
cost and ganito using the ancient
samurai cutscene technique is definitely
in keeping with that ethos I should know
bit know the difference between honor
and victory the divine air is coming
with me as you head into the ash unit
outskirts still thinking about how you
totally beat Genichiro and it isn't fair
remember to head upwards and to the left
as soon as you arrive at the cannon
section there's a memorial mob merchant
up here who sells firecrackers 500 Sen
and it is one of the strongest
prosthetic tools in the game and as soon
as you clear the cannon section double
back here before you fight the ogre
there's a merchant tucked away and he's
in a nuke that you wouldn't really think
to visit any AMA dressed in patches and
tatters we'll trade information for a
hundred and fifty Sen before he upgrades
his wares his prized possession is the
phantom kunai it's this shuriken upgrade
that you can purchase for 3,000 cent and
it takes a little while for you to work
towards this and one should oaken now
costs two spirit emblems but it's the
best method you have really to do damage
to enemies at a distance and this is
kind of good against bosses that require
a little bit more health damage before
their posture begins to fall and on a
Yama's ambitions have only just begun do
you mind finding out what
you know summer I want right now you
tell me that I can sell it to them the
escena are low on salt having used it
all up during their constant warfare you
can get this information on the bridge
by the lake at the back of a scenic
console next he needs an assistant to
help him loot the battlefield there's a
peddler named Donna Yamanashi know
castle looking for help you should give
him a hand a perfect companion for Anna
llaman to manipulate is Katara a gentle
giant found early on in semper temple
give Katara the red-and-white pinwheel
and he'll come around the idea all right
I'll do it
I'll go and see this unlocks a few more
sugars and an infinite store of black
gunpowder and scrap iron
but for the ending to their quest line
I'm gonna keep you around till the end
of the video because it contains
spoilers to the right of the cannon bara
is a hidden drop down to a ledge
containing a bunch of good items more
interesting though is this bit of
snakeskin hanging from a tree it's a
great little piece of environmental
storytelling and it tells you that the
snake really gets around this area a
couple of tips in these videos are going
to be lifted from popular speedrunning
strats the most useful one I've found so
far is this way of dealing with the
chained ogre
so you crush a GUCH in sugar walk up to
this brazier and then take a sharp left
this enables a backstab while he's still
chained and it's a good idea no matter
how experienced you are because let's be
honest we've all been hit by this grab
attack after you defeat the ogre you can
actually take a fairly pointless
shortcut - headless if you like this gap
in the wall enables a wall jump to this
ledge allowing you to open this door
from behind and enabling you to die -
headless faster if you didn't know all
headless enemies drop spirit fall
consumables which are infinite use
versions of the sugar items that consume
three spirit emblems they don't last
quite as long but if you have to divine
confetti handy then you have a shot at
beating this headless which drops my
favourite sugar
and while we're here did you know that
sekito actually has a passive ability
called
night eye it's explained in one of the
loading screens and you can actually see
it activate when you're in a dark place
and speaking of eyes after this
encounter look to the right of the first
idle you come across you'll find a small
simple assassin who dreams of marrying
the great serpent this is weird so kill
him and you'll receive the herb catalog
scrap which details where exactly to
offer oneself this explains the
palanquin within the valley as there are
two examples in the game of these being
used for marriage and then being used in
this really formal ceremony might
explain why the snake briefly stops its
aggression towards us when it spots us
going inside in an earlier video we
talked about what happens if you don't
take the second death blow on main
bosses so maybe something will happen to
you if you don't take a second death
blow on the snake later on hmm your
first death blow on yo boo refills a
resurrection which you can use to get an
extra line of dialogue out of him quite
a few main bosses react in this way
astonished that you're still able to
stand he says a third resurrection is
possible with a Jesus statue and while
gyobu says nothing here this technique
will be used in our next video which is
about uh scheana castle which reveals a
fascinating little piece of law about a
character here so subscribe and click
the notification Bell thing as well so
you don't miss it
after gyobu go up the staircase and have
a chat with the guy in the tengu mask he
gives you a task to kill rats vermin
that he says are creeping about ash in
his lands tempo assassins count as rats
and there's a group of them to the right
of the castle gate go up there kill them
then go back and you receive the ash in
a skill tree which includes honestly
probably the most powerful abilities in
sekito you've got deflection
enhancements you've got enhancements to
combat and it also contains at the
and what is arguably the best combat art
in the game it Chi mangy double but
we'll talk about combat arts in another
video above the tengu accessible with a
few ledge hangs is a set of prayer beads
which you might have missed and I should
also mention there's a gourd seed around
the corner at the memorial mob just
remember you have to scroll down I
appreciate how gimmicky and well
presented the blazing bullfighters right
but this fight probably is one of the
less enjoyable fights in the game
luckily if you want to skip it you can
only do this on New Game+ because you do
miss out on a prayer bead so you hop up
to this guard tower you ledge jump at an
angle off this wall and you grapple onto
the ledge go to the top of the roof
runoff at this exact angle as late as
you can and sort of curve your character
around the tree take your second jump
right here and pray you don't want after
doing the slide for 20 minutes I think
I'll just fight the bull next time to
reward your prayer and your devotion you
arrived at this old woman right after
the skip actually show her how devoted
you are by consuming all of your
important items in front of her as a
reward for praying you get other items
of equal value the third prayer does net
you some divine confetti which is a
pretty rare item this early in the game
so it's worth it for that on the bridge
opposite this woman are two really
nondescript soldiers it's easy to run
past them but don't because one of them
actually drops The Gatehouse key which
you can use in the reservoir to loot key
booze broken horn so before some of you
type I learned nothing new from this
video did you know that the horn itself
is from gyobu zone helmet it was snapped
off during the rebellion and that its
description reveals that after he was
defeated ish in a Sheena was so
impressed by gurus strength that he
awarded him with the spear of none other
than shoes and Tamura the same general
that we see his shin defeat in the
opening cutscene
as we talked about in the Hirata Estates
video this is in Oscar a man blinded and
crippled during his fight with Lady
butterfly years later his mother gives
us the means to travel back to the
hirato States talking about the divine
Prince endlessly but did you know that
when you kill lady butterfly both her
and her son die young master the events
of the past have been resolved the
following four facts are really good but
they take place after acquiring the
mortal blade and after completing the
final sequence of the game as always I
have an escape route you can go click
the merge link down below and it'll
evacuate you from this video to a safer
place that spoiler free because you
shouldn't continue watching if you have
not finished the game during the siege
of a sheena castle you can take a
shinobi kite to the ushe inner outskirts
unlocking an invaluable section of the
game here in at the outskirts wall
stairway is probably the best farming
location in the game so from the statue
simply head backwards towards the bridge
backstabbing all the way and you'll
receive a boatload of XP gold and rare
upgrade materials 17 maybe it's best if
you did miss this one honestly when we
left Anna Yama he was overjoyed with the
companion we brought him but now during
the siege of a sheena castle he's bitten
off more than he could chew
he took it all my money my stock
everything but coach ro drove them away
at least right pal
the big guys falling asleep yes
he's sleeping soundly please don't make
that face
there's nothing for you to be sad about
good sir oh that's right I stowed away
something good something just for you my
last piece of product interested the
purpose of this quest line is to give
you the promissory note it only costs
one cent but it discounts the cost of
all items by 10% which is a nice boost
because you're going to want to clear
out merchant stock before new game+ and
it carries over into the beyond ascend
saved is a sin earned unfortunately this
is the end of Anu Yama and Katara
after you acquire the mortal blade don't
forget to give a merciful death to
Haeundae the undying and as he prepares
for death he reveals the name of a close
friend splendid I must give my thanks to
sekito sake Joe is the sculptor a man
who hyundai understandably would have
become close to after all of his
immortal years for just as secular
translates roughly to one-armed Wolf's
sake Joe would translate roughly to one
armed orangutan that's because ROH
translates to wolf and there's something
called a shoujo which is a sort of
Japanese monkey spirit it has a red face
red hair
a fondness for alcohol which
descriptions that fit the sculptor
especially as you'll see in the next few
facts later in the game Emma leaves to
tend to kudo and oisin at the top of
arch in a castle and while she's gone
there during the siege of Hashanah the
sculptor - takes this opportunity to
leave if you talk to the merchants here
around this time he mentions that the
sculptor left muttering something about
the flames and past the corpses of Anna
Yama and kotero past this squadron of
government soldiers and past some
red-hot claw marks there is the demon of
hatred terrorizing the landscape
this is sekito it's the sculptor
engulfed by shudders wrath so sekito
himself recognized the sculptor when I
fought him which as I would come to
realize is because i eavesdropped a lot
and i shared a lot of sake which led to
my character figuring out who the demon
of hatred is if you don't do these
things throughout the game sekito does
not recognize the demon of hatred but
the demon of hatred always recognizes
you
I hope you're preparing to cry over the
next few weeks
this old woman always was foreshadowing
a demon appearing because back then she
asks where do you think all that hatred
from the war where do you think it goes
and now her dialogue here at the end
depends on whether you knew the demon's
identity this whole time and of course
now you do the carve and sculpt Buddha's
for so long only to be raised in the
flames of hatred and turn into a demon
it was the fate he made for himself to
pay for his own mistakes and you put an
end to that you sent him on his way
I'm sure he's grateful for that I know
you're all aching for a low video
pennant while I do have them in the
works trust me
I enjoy talking about the gameplay more
right now as you all wrap up your own
playthroughs it's actually been a
difficult last few months I have to
balance the needs of my firstborn child
who was born in January and I also have
to balance the needs of YouTube and
twitch and also teespring
as well so thank you for being patient
big thank you to all of you who actually
bought a t-shirt over the last few weeks
it's doing really well I didn't think
anyone wanted merch but now I'm at the
point where I think I should actually
work with an artist every month and
throw a ton of money at them so that
they can make cool designs for you guys
which if you know me you probably know
that I dig that sort of stuff I love it
then I'll see you next time remember to
ring the bell if you want to be notified
of new videos and I'll see them